[Aplausos]
[Música]
bacuri deputado falava ainda combatendo
a cutícula em bacuri pintar numa
narrativa combat barbie uma diretriz
ainda na batida com button vai perguntar
vai poder escutar não dava ainda
combatiam taco de lutar
[Música]
na beira do rio
nada melhor do que a dele
na base da brincadeira
o dele
o marido
em maio passado
nada
sabe nada
ae
[Música]
o interesse
na bahia
rodrigo está na maneira que pagando bem
dotado
[Música]
eu
[Aplausos]
obrigada a não mais o design é a nossa
safra é de fato a minha inspiração não
só como vou tentar técnica nós como
motivação para né
para meu retorno é reinventar reconhecer
reconciliar e conquistar o espaço
coreográfico que fazemos no nosso dia a
dia faz isso comigo própria e convidando
outras pessoas a fazê lo comigo vou vir
aqui hoje antes de tudo obrigado a
organização pelo convite seja muito
extensa nem nada de especial
o meu trabalho como performer e como
profissional na vida é trazermos a
trazer a conexão com aquilo que a
essência do ser humano na tribo
somos hoje em dia a dança afro tribal
foi levada para a américa do sul onde
outras tribos também existiam por outras
tribos uma tribo essa europa e e toda
essa fusão traz uma certa alegria uma
certa coxa américa do sul
a dança afro americana como a que foi
apresentada no meu trabalho aqui
por que a américa é um continente não é
um país é faz parte de trás então esta
fusão de tudo o que aconteceu no
continente americano
o resultado dessa fusão já também
presentes nesta sala hoje é nossa única
sul-americana aqui presente
haverá também cruzamentos com
dissidentes diretos e africanos e de
outros continentes asiático
principalmente tivemos também uma
presença contínua sem fogo e essa essa
fusão que faz hoje em dia a tribo que
todos nós somos é a forma mais
importante trazermos isto é percebermos
que apesar do nosso vizinho lado ou
daquela comunidade mais afastada ter uma
forma distinta o diferente que nós não
percebemos o funcionário de viver a sua
vida todos fazemos parte da mesma tribo
que esta tribo que é sermos o ser humano
ea nossa grande mãe tá fazendo um
chamado o chamado para nós nos
conectarmos com a essência do nosso
coração é nossa grande mãe é o planeta
terra e vou fazer um apenas um pequeno
um pequeno chamado é a percebermos que
estamos vivos é isso que eu faço
era pra fazer no início mas não deu
tempo vou fazer agora que é o seguinte
com essas todas as suas dez
acho que é a lógica
[Música]
[Aplausos]